[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend wie steht es um
unsere Debattenkultur außerhalb aber
auch innerhalb des Deutschen Bundestags
wer diese Woche Donnerstag die
Diskussion im Parlament rund um das
Gebäude Energiegesetz verfolgt hat kann
komprimiert zusammenfassen stammte
Sprüche und drunter kommen nicht nur an
den Rändern vor der Ton ordinär bis
daneben und die sozialen Medien sie
dienen als schallverstärker doch wohin
führen Methoden der Antidemokraten bzw
Populisten und was ist der Ausweg
darüber habe ich mit dem ehemaligen
Bundesinnenminister der CDU Thomas der
mir sehr gesprochen sofort Dominik
Lessmeister mit destruktiven Tönen
es ist eine scharf geführte Debatte um
das neue heizungsgesetz nicht nur in den
Medien Erding vor einer Woche 13000
Menschen darunter auch afd-anhänger und
viele unzufriedene demonstrieren gegen
das heizungsgesetz der Regierung reden
in Bier zählt man mir und einen
stellvertretender Ministerpräsident der
austeilt gegen die Ampel in Berlin
es ist der Punkt erreicht wo endlich die
schweigende große Mehrheit dieses Landes
sich die Demokratie wieder zurückholen
muss und denen in Berlin sagen ihr habt
wohl den Arsch offen dort meine Damen
und Herren
gibt es hier noch einen Unterschied zur
Wortwahl der AFD warum sind die Töne so
schrill fragen sich nicht nur die
Kritiker Albaners es geht insgesamt
immer weniger um die Sache erste Lesung
des neuen Gebäude Energiegesetz am
Donnerstag im Bundestag der Ton ist zum
Teil aber die näher die Stimmung giftig
wie sie kommunizieren und wie sie Angst
auslösen ist unterirdisch ist zum kotzen
oder rotzen Sie uns hier etwas hin
Heizungs Hammer ist nicht verschoben er
kommt es ist ein Gesetz für die Tonne
Schrott vielen Dank
verfällt der politische Diskurs den
Populismus es lohnt sich alte reden
anzuschauen von Herbert Wehner von Franz
Josef Strauß auch damals gab es bewusste
tabu-brüche
geht's ihnen so wie göppels damit
operiert hat nichts anderes sich sie
sind nämlich genauso dumm in dieser
Frage wie jeder wird die besten Anhänger
Heinrich gewesen ihr seid die besten
Nazi die es je gegeben hat wie
populistisch darf eine Volkspartei heute
sein zuletzten der Kritik auch CDU-Chef
Friedrich Merz z.B mit seiner Aussage zu
Migranten Kindern und dann wollen Sie
diese Kinder zur Ordnung rufen und die
Folge ist dass die Väter in den Schulen
erscheinen und sich das verbitten
insbesondere wenn es sich um Lehrerinnen
handelt dass sie ihre Söhne die kleinen
Paschas damals etwas
zurechtweisen da fängt es an in Berlin
direkt spricht März heute von einer
krisenhaften Zuspitzungen unserer
Demokratie von Unzufriedenheit und
Besorgnis und deswegen finde ich sollte
man solche Menschen die da am Vorgehen
am vorletzten Samstag in Erding
demonstriert haben nicht gleich alle in
die rechte Ecke bringen wenn man das tut
dann sind sie irgendwann da auch sie war
noch nie um eine Provokation verlegen
Sarah Wagenknecht setzt auf Themen die
auch im rechten Lager verfangen findet
das aber
legitimen und das geht vor allem von den
Grünen aus aber nicht nur ein Problem
mit freier offener Diskussion haben also
das Meinungsspektrum wird verengt und
alles was da nicht reinpasst in das was
einige für das Gebotene oder richtige
halten das wird in eine Rechtecke
gestellt und man merkt gar nicht dass
man damit am Ende die rechte sogar stark
macht Ukraine Krieg Inflation Klimakrise
der Politik anspruchsvoller und gerade
jetzt wird der politische Diskurs immer
lauter
wohin führen insbesondere
rechtsnationale Töne wenn sie aus der
Mitte kommen macht man sie salonfähig
gefährden sie die Demokratie erreicht
man damit irgendetwas konstruktives und
damit ein schönen guten Abend nach
Dresden Thomas de Maizière ehemaliger
Innen- und Verteidigungsminister aktuell
kirchentagspräsident
guten Abend hätte mir sehr harte
Debatten mit zugespitzten Formulierungen
gab es ja früher auch haben wir gerade
im Beitrag gesehen was hat sich jenseits
der sozialen Medien die sozusagen eine
Art Verstärker sind geändert
das sollte Debatte kommt ja aus dem
Lateinischen heißt im Grunde auseinander
hauen das ist schon hart das darf auch
hart sein geändert hat sich dass wir
jetzt eine extremistische Partei im
Deutschen Bundestag haben und dadurch
eine Schärfe in den Deutschen Bundestag
gekommen ist die Version nicht hatten
auch von der Linken kommen manchmal
solche Töne und es gibt eine Art
Versuchung dann in die Mitte hinein mit
gleicher Münze zurück zu schlagen und
das ist schlecht aber das kommt ja nicht
nur von den Rändern die verrogen der
Sprache im Parlament Schmähungen und
Dämonisierung der demokratischen
Gegenseite wohin führt das
ja zunächst soll man nicht den Untergang
beschweren herbert Wehner und
Französisch Strauß waren auch keine
Waisen Kinder Joschka Fischer hat mal
den Präsidenten so bezeichnet wie es
jetzt hier Sonntagabend nicht
wiederholen will Helmut Schmidt der
großheater als junger Mann den
Spitznamen Schmidt Schnauze also Politik
ist kein Mädchen panzernat aber es muss
Grenzen geben das heißt ja nicht umsonst
hohes Haus und das heißt da muss man
anständig miteinander umgehen das kann
hart sein man kann sich dann machen
entschuldigen wenn es nicht
erfolgt und das ist unser Problem wir
haben ein resonanzbogen in den Boden in
der Gesellschaft der dann solche
Äußerungen verstärkt werden die das
sagen kann ich das ja erst recht sagen
hassinseln hassblasen die das gierig
aufgreifen und in die Mitte das Gift
rhetorische Gift verspritzen das ist die
Gefahr
für das nicht vielleicht dann auch zu
dass ich den Räume auch für Lösungen
verkleinern weil im Grunde auch jede
politische Idee vom Gegner ja sofort
zerrissen wird und dann mit Waren oder
mit Zwang oder auch mit Verbot
degradiert wird
man kann man kann schon
Argumente und Positionen der anderen
Seite hart kritisieren aber wenn dann in
extremen Formulierungen formuliert wird
Meinungsdiktatur Ökodiktatur Rassist und
was man sie alles denken kann dann ist
ein alter rhetorischer Trick dreht sich
die Beweislast um derjenige der muss
sein das ist es aber gar nicht man geht
weg von der Sache Ebene und das
lenkt ab von den Themen und je mehr
Themen wir diskutieren umso besser für
die demokratische Mitte je mehr extreme
wir diskutieren umso besser für die
extrem und alles andere führt natürlich
dann auch zu Politikverdrossenheit diese
empörungsspirale die sie ja auch gerade
beschrieben haben die bedienen im Grunde
fast alle Parteien mittlerweile oder
alle Parteien auch ihre auch die Union
quasi mit Populismus gegen Populisten
hat man da gehört Energie Stasi kleine
Paschas für jemanden der wie sie
konservativ christliche Werte in sich
trägt ist das akzeptabel
sie haben jetzt viele Begriffe einander
verwendet verwendet also von kleinen
Paschas in Schulen da reden nicht nur
Friedrich Merz sondern auch viele
Menschen auf der Straße die anderen
Begriffe sind nicht in Ordnung vor allen
Dingen helfen sie auch der es ist so
aber die anderen Begriffe helfen auch
nicht der CDU es gibt einige vielleicht
hardcoreanhänger die finden es gut die
Mitte und wir sind eine bürgerliche
Partei der Mitte wird dadurch eher
abgestoßen also es ist demokratisch
nicht gut es ist taktisch nicht gut und
es ist nicht anziehend und wir müssen ja
die Menschen anziehen und nicht abstoßen
was braucht es denn ihrer Meinung nach
damit die demokratischen Parteien wieder
ansehen und Zuspruch erfahren denn auch
das haben wir gerade im Beitrag gesehen
Menschen die zudem muss gehen wo
Politiker Politikerin auf der Bühne
eigentlich gar kein Wort mehr sagen
können weil sie permanent nur noch
ausgebucht und angeschrieben werden
ja da ist eine Diskussionskultur auch
über den Deutschen Bundestag hinaus in
die Gesellschaft eingerissen erinnern
sich mal an die Geigen für Angela Merkel
und Sigmar Gabriel hier in Dresden und
und dieses Geschrei das ist Unsicherheit
das heißt ich will euch nicht hören ihr
hört uns nicht zu wird gerufen und
gleichzeitig werden jemand da ist wird
nicht zugehört das ist ein
besorgniserregende Entwicklung was man
dagegen machen kann am besten ist gut
regieren und gut opponieren
Kommunikationsstrategien helfen da gar
nichts mit den Menschen reden gute
Arbeit leisten und bessere Konzepte als
Opposition anbieten und nicht so viel
auf Kommunikationsberater hören die
irgendwie sowas vorschlagen
manche Politiker sagen ja wir müssen
halt so reden damit uns die Leute auch
am Stammtisch verstehen Claudia
Pechstein ehemalige Eisschnellläuferin
hat auf dem cdu-konvent eine Rede
gehalten sie waren auch dort in
Polizeiuniform das sorgt jetzt für
Diskussionen Stichwort Neutralitätsgebot
aber es gibt noch einen anderen Punkt
der kritisiert wird zum Beispiel als sie
gesagt hat wenn man abgelehnte
Asylbewerber abschieben würde dann
würden
ältere und Frauen ohne
ängstliche Blicke Zitat in der Bahn
auskommen ist das Populismus oder
Markenkern der CDU
nein das kann man sagen im übrigen war
es ja auch nicht ich kann die
CDU-Mitglied sie hat als Expertin der
cdu-ratschläge gegeben und wenn man
gesagt wird man soll irgendwie dem Volk
aus mal schauen das gefällt mir das
ganze Bild gefällt mir nicht auch wenn
es so Martin Lutherstadt das heißt ja so
irgendwie wir da oben sprechen irgendwie
eine gehobene Sprachen das Volk spricht
irgendwie so eine Volkssprache nein ähm
man muss ganz normal reden und ein
unanständiger Witz und eine Beschimpfung
ist in der Politik wie in der
Bevölkerung nicht in Ordnung das ist das
ist der Punkt wenn man so redet wie die
Menschen und nicht abgehoben und sich
nicht gemein macht mit irgendwelchen
vulgären Ausdrücken dann ist es in
Ordnung das ist gerade in Großstädten
viele Menschen gibt die Angst haben in
U-Bahn nachts das ist so aber gar nicht
entschuldigen Sie dass ich aber stellt
sie da nicht ein Zusammenhang Herz
Wissen zwischen ausländischen aussehen
und im Grunde einer völlig allgemeinen
Gefahr also das ist doch genau worüber
wir jetzt gerade gesprochen haben sie
verkürzt doch damit spielt und führt
Ängste
ich hätte eher diese Firma Leerung nicht
empfohlen ich hätte ja übrigens auch
empfohlen dass ohne Uniform zu machen
aber davon abgesehen ob das jetzt junge
macho-mäßig auftretende Männer sind
welche Art auch immer es gibt dieses
Gefühl und dagegen kann man etwas machen
es wird ja auch viel gemacht Kameras in
Zügen Polizeipräsenz die stärker wird
Sauberkeit auf Bahnhöfen hilft das sind
die richtigen Maßnahmen mit dem Thema
Abschiebung was schwierig genug ist hat
das nichts zu tun zuspitzen verkürzen
schwarz-weiß denken damit drängt man die
wir heute auch gesehen haben in der Flut
der Nachricht natürlich durch auch bei
denen und differenziert gesagt Medien
die das dann leider schneller aufgreifen
als die Grautöne auch wir müssen Blick
aber ich wollte nur sagen auch wir
müssen uns an dieser Stelle hinterfragen
Thomas die mir sehr vielen Dank für Ihre
Zeit und für das Gespräch
schöne Grüße
immer noch wird gerätselt wer wird für
die Zerstörung des
carhowka Staudamms verantwortlich ist
den New York Times veröffentlichte heute
einen Bericht der nahe liegt das
Russland dahinter stecken dürfte laut
Ingenieuren und Sprengstoffexperten gebe
es Hinweise die klar darauf hindeuten
Zitat dass der Damm durch eine Explosion
lahmgelegt wurde die von der Seite
ausgelöst wurde die in kontrolliert
Russland die Wahrheit werden wir aber
wohl erst erfahren wenn eine
vollständige Untersuchung des Darms
stattgefunden hat wenn sie denn
überhaupt stattfinden sollte welche
Konsequenzen die Zerstörung des
Staudamms für die Menschen hat Alissa
jung
kein Wasser nicht einen Tropfen Irina
Trojan lebt in nicopol im Süden der
Ukraine seit der mutmaßlichen Staudamm
Sprengung ist in der Stadt die
Wasserversorgung zusammengebrochen
wir füllen Wasser in diese Eimer und
Baden mit Hilfe von Schüsseln wir gießen
dann das Wasser hier rein und dann
spülen wir damit die Toilette ab aber
was sollen wir tun es gibt keinen
anderen Weg
immer noch leben rund 50.000 Menschen
hier und müssen nun das Wasser zum
Kochen und Waschen in Kanistern sammeln
gehen
wenn wir müde von der Arbeit nach Hause
kommen dann gehen wir nur einmal am Tag
Wasser holen nur um das Gesicht zu
waschen auf Toilette zu gehen und Tee zu
machen um unsere Körper zu waschen
müssen wir am Wochenende Wasser holen
manchmal stehen sie hier zwei Stunden
Schlange und am Ende gibt es kein Wasser
mehr heute hat Irina Glück sie ist
rechtzeitig dort sie sammelt nicht nur
für sich Irinas Sozialarbeiterin und
versorgt 13 ältere Frauen die nicht mehr
selbst laufen können bei fast 30 Grad
ist es wichtig dass sie nicht
dehydrieren erzählt Irina noch seit der
Staudamm zerstört worden ist ist der
Wasserpegel des nipro um mehrere Meter
gefallen auf der anderen Seite steht das
Atomkraftwerk von saporisha seit den
ersten Kriegswochen russisch besetzt
waren die Ukraine hier in Nicole und die
russischen Truppen gegenüber bislang
durch eine riesige Wasserfläche getrennt
sieht es jetzt so aus
nur 12 km Luftlinie mit Blick auf das
AKW leben die Menschen in nicopol seit
einem Jahr unter russisch Beschuss bei
mir sind nur die Fenster kaputt aber bei
den Nachbarn gab es Treffer bei ihnen
ist es direkt in die Garage reingeflogen
ich war damals zu Hause es war
unheimlich wir wurden mit Kat Raketen
beschossen
der Beschuss die Wasserversorgung das
Atomkraftwerk in unmittelbarer Nähe der
Leiter der Region nicopol hat große
Sorge um die Zukunft seiner Stadt
es gibt keine praktischen Modelle und es
gibt keine praktischen Beispiele für
diese Situation dementsprechend wissen
wir nicht was passieren wird aber es
scheint mir dass dies ein großes Problem
ist dass dringend ein Eingreifen der
internationalen Gemeinschaft erfordert
er sucht nach Lösungen um die
Wasserversorgung wieder herzustellen
solange sind sie in nicopol auf ihre
Feuerwehr angewiesen
und wir blicken jetzt nach China US
Außenminister blinken ist zu Gast in
Peking eine lang erwartete Reise
allerdings Gundula mit ziemlich vielen
Problemen
gemeinsam aber mit seinem Kollegen
ziehen Gang hat blinken ein positives
Fazit der ersten Gespräche gezogen trotz
der angespannten Beziehungen zwischen
den USA und China beide sprachen von
offenen Diskussionen mit blinken besucht
erstmals seit fünf Jahren ein
US-Außenminister wieder China laut sind
ist das größte Risiko in den Beziehungen
der Streit um Taiwan die Volksrepublik
beansprucht das mit den USA Verbündete
Taiwan als eigenes Territorium
in Wien hat die Polizei nach eigenen
Angaben möglicherweise einen
Terroranschlag auf die Regenbogenparade
vereitelt drei Verdächtige is
Sympathisanten im Alter von 14 17 und 20
Jahren wurden gestern festgenommen bei
Hausdurchsuchungen wurden Waffen
sichergestellt die Parade für Vielfalt
und Toleranz mit mehr als 300.000
Besuchern konnte kurz darauf wie geplant
zum 27 Mal stattfinden
bundesinnenministerin Fräser ist mit
ihrem französischen Kollegen nach
Tunesien gereist um über legale
Migration zu beraten ebenso wie über die
Rückführung von Menschen ohne
Bleiberecht in Deutschland und das
Vorgehen gegen Menschen Schmuggel das
Sterben auf dem Mittelmeer wie jetzt vor
griechenland müsse ein Ende nehmen
zugleich ermitteln die griechischen
Behörden gemeinsam mit der italienischen
Polizei und Europol gegen die
Schleuserbande und ihre Drahtzieher
bei der Volksabstimmung über ein
ehrgeizigeres Klimaschutzgesetz in der
Schweiz hat eine Mehrheit dafür mutiert
es sieht vor dass das Land bis 2050
klimaneutral wird das Referendum geht
auf eine Initiative von Wissenschaftlern
und Klimaschützern zurück die die
Gletscher in den Schweizer Alpen
schützen wollen letztes Jahr sind diese
so schnell geschmolzen wie noch nie seit
Beginn der Aufzeichnungen
Hitze Dürre Trockenheit wenn man sich
den zwölf Monatsverlauf bis heute
anschaut stellt man fest es gibt einige
Regionen da erholt sich der Boden
einfach gar nicht mehr gelb bedeutet
nicht okay sondern schon ungewöhnlich
trocken das ganze reicht im Farbverlauf
bis hin zu außergewöhnlicher Dürre in
dunkel rot die Messungen in 1,8 Metern
Tiefe zeigen also ein erschreckendes
Bild aber was nun kann man einfach auf
wochenlang Regen hoffen oder doch
Umdenken wie könnte eine Bepflanzung
aussehen die mit diesen Bedingungen klar
kommt Deutschlands bester Wald macht es
vor der corinawald im Norden
Brandenburgs ist im wahrsten Sinne ein
ausgezeichneter Wald Antje klingt bei
ein feucht Biotop gibt es in
Deutschlands Wälder nur noch selten es
ist einfach zu trocken der Corinna Wald
er hält dem Klimawandel gut stand denn
es ist ein Mischwald sein Umbau begann
vor Jahrzehnten in Zusammenarbeit mit
der Wissenschaft
wir wissen wie viel Grundwasser unter
welchem Wald gebildet wird welche
Baumarten besonders gut sind um eben
auch Grundwasser gerade im Winter in die
Bodenschichten zu leiten und von daher
können wir natürlich Empfehlungen
aussprechen dass eben mehr Laubbaumarten
und weniger Kiefer sehr positiv sind
wenn wir Grundwasser erzeugen wollen
schon zu DDR-Zeiten diente dieser Wald
als freilichtlabor bis heute einmalig in
Europa buchen und uralte Eichen all das
wächst hier 75 75 seit Generationen
achten försterinnen und Förster hier auf
die Balance zwischen Naturschutz und
wirtschaftlichen Ansprüchen um für den
Klimawandel fit zu sein damit so alte
wertvolle Eichen entstehen können ist es
wichtig dass der Förster immer ein Auge
auf diesen Bestand hat und eine
Durchforstung eine vorsicht hier
Durchforstung immer zum richtigen
Zeitpunkt einsetzt dieses Wissen geben
die Förster hier an die nächste
Generation weiter Studierende der
Hochschule für nachhaltige Entwicklung
im nahen Eberswalde sind heute vor Ort
auf einer Versuchsfläche das überlege ob
ich die 8001 auch noch rausnehme das
hier halt ein bisschen mehr Licht ist
dass die Eichen ein bisschen besser
kommen ein Teil des Waldes ist digital
erfasst nun simulieren sie mit Tablets
welche Bäume stehen bleiben sollten und
welche nicht dabei geht es nicht nur um
den finanziellen Wert sondern auch um
den Wert als Wohnstätte und Lebensraum
als Habitat den ein Baum hat
trockene Äste spricht Helme wassertöpfe
Mose Flechten Bewuchs etc und das wird
dann in mikroabitat Punkte übersetzt und
das
repräsentiert den ökologischen Wert des
Einzelnen Baumes die verschiedenen
Maßnahmen machen den Corinna Wald zu
einem der auf vielfältige Weise dem
Klimawandel trotzen kann Mischwald
Stärken gut durch Forsten den
Grundwasserpegel halten mit so einer
Einstellung kommt man auch mit dem
Problem im Klimawandel gut zurecht aber
man nicht an seinen Grundsätzen festhält
sondern sich überlegt und neu orientiert
und sich selber in Frage stellt macht
man alles richtig versucht der Natur
über die Schulter zu schauen die
Hoffnung ist groß dass korin ein
Beispiel für ganz Deutschland sein
könnte für den Wald der Zukunft
damit wieder ins Jetzt und jetzt geht es
hier weiter mit dem Sport unter richtig
guten Nachricht im Finale der Handball
Champions League hat der SC Magdeburg
zum zweiten Mal den Sieg erringen können
und feiert der deutsche Vizemeister
setzte sich vor 20.000 Fans in Köln im
Endspiel gegen den polnischen Meister
barlinik industria Kieze mit dem
deutschen Nationaltorwart Andreas Wolf
mit 30 zu 29 nach Verlängerung durch
Formel 1 Weltmeister Max Verstappen hat
den Großen Preis von Kanada gewonnen und
damit den sechsten Sieg im achten Rennen
der Saison eingefahren der Niederländer
setzte sich in seinem Red Bull vor
Fernando Alonso im ersten Martin und
Lewis Hamilton im Mercedes durch die
Partien für die erste Runde des
DFB-Pokals sind ausgelost worden wieder
interessante Begegnungen so spielt
Rekordmeister Bayern München Ende
September bei Drittliga Aufsteiger
Preußen Münster und Pokalsieger RB
Leipzig ist bei 2 Liga Aufsteiger Wien
Wiesbaden zu Gast schon ab 11 August
empfängt Regionalligisten Lok Leipzig
Eintracht Frankfurt und außerdem gibt es
ein südbadisches Duell Oberligist SV
Oberachern trifft auf bundesliga
erstmal
eigentlich war das Museum Hamburger
Bahnhof in Berlin dem Untergang geweiht
vor 16 Jahren hatte der Senat
entschieden das Grundstück samt Museum
an einen österreichischen
Immobilienentwickler zu verkaufen ohne
eine kulturelle Nutzung festzuschreiben
und sogar bis zwischendurch tatsächlich
Überlegungen aus dem Altbau ein Hotel zu
machen nach einigem Hin und Her ist nun
alles anders gekommen die
Nationalgalerie der Gegenwart wurde
umgebaut sie leuchtet und fasziniert
auch dank der neuen Direktoren von der
Wiedergeburt eines Prachtstücks Stefan
Merseburger
sie sind in Scharen gekommen mehr als
32.000 Besucher an diesem Wochenende
Open House freier Eintritt im Hamburger
Bahnhof dieser wichtige Standort für
moderne Kunst ist seit November 2022
gesichert das wird gefeiert der Bund hat
den Bahnhof gekauft die
dahinterliegenden recallen das Land
Berlin für insgesamt 160 Millionen Euro
Steuergelder
wir wollen jetzt eben zeigen das werden
öffentliches Hauses das wirklich allen
von uns gehört allen offen steht jeder
hat das Recht es kennenzulernen hinter
die Kulissen zu erstaunen genau das ist
die Botschaft von dem openhaus
sie sind Symbole für Zuneigung Fürsorge
und Liebe riesige Kirschblüten ziehen in
die neue Dauerausstellung die
ausgeschlachteten Autowracks sind ein
neuankauf zu sehen gibt es auch
Leihgaben und Fundstücke aus den Depots
die Werke sind Teil der Sammlung für das
21 Jahrhundert die die beiden neuen
Direktoren des Hamburger Bahnhofs Samba
dawin und Till fellrad aufbauen und
zeigen
die Künstler die wir gekauft haben und
kaufen sind Teil der einmaligen
Kunstszene von Berlin die Arbeiten die
wir zeigen erzählen die Geschichten der
Stadt sie erzählen von Entwicklungen
Wandel den großen und den weniger großen
Augenblicken
Robert Rauschenberg war zufällig in
Berlin als die Mauer fiel Martin
Kippenberger war über ihren Abriss
entsetzt Fantas geschichts vergessen
Rainer Fetting feierte die Freizügigkeit
West Berlins Stillleben aus dem
Prenzlauer Berg 80er Jahre von Manfred
Paul das Zusammenwachsen des Landes
mühsamer Aufschwung Ost der Abzug der
letzten russischen Soldaten ein Fenster
des Palastes der Republik Hammer und
Sichel fehlen
Berlin war und ist noch immer ein Magnet
für internationale Künstler auch das
macht die Sammlung deutlich Eva und
Adele Gesamtkunstwerk und Ikonen der
Berliner performance-szene sind auch
dabei mit einer Schenkung Polaroids aus
30 Jahren für die Sammlung des 21
jahrhunderts
großartig das war längst fällig weil es
gibt so viele Künstlerinnen und Künstler
die in Berlin leben und arbeiten die zum
Teil nicht berücksichtigt wurden und das
ist fantastisch auch so einen großen
Überblick zu bekommen
neue inhaltliche Ausrichtung Öffnung
nach außen Aufbruch es tut sich was im
Hamburger Bahnhof
das war ein schöner Einblick jetzt gibt
es einen kurzen Ausblick auf die nächste
Woche von Christian von Rechenberg
[Musik]
was geschah Mitte der 90er Jahre in der
katholischen Gemeinde im bayerischen
Garching und wer wusste davon das soll
das Landgericht Traunstein ab Dienstag
klären ein heute 39 Jahre alter Mann
will Schadenersatz in sechsstelliger
Höhe da in der damalige Pfarrer sexuell
missbraucht haben soll beklagt sind
neben dem Erzbistum auch die damals
amtierenden Erzbischöfe die den Fahrer
trotz einschlägiger Vorstrafen lediglich
innerhalb Bayerns versetzten einer davon
der spätere und mittlerweile verstorbene
Papst Benedikt XVI ob und wie weit das
Gericht seine Verantwortung bejaht und
die Schadensersatzpflicht seiner Erben
feststellt
das Paradies macht sich klimafest auch
Länder im globalen Süden wie etwa die
Karibikinsel Barbados müssen die
Klimaziele von Paris einhalten weniger
CO2-Ausstoß mehr Gebäude wie diese die
stürmen und extremen trotzen das alles
kostet Geld mehr Geld als der globale
Süden aufbieten kann die internationale
Staatengemeinschaft soll helfen in
welcher Höhe und für welche Projekte
darüber berät am Donnerstag ein Gipfel
in Paris Gastgeber dort Barbados und
Frankreichs Präsident macron
dass ich Südafrika trotz des Überfalls
auf die Ukraine mit Russland seit an
seit präsentiert hat Gründe etwa der
frühere gemeinsame Kampf gegen die
Apartheid diese Solidarität macht Afrika
zu einem schwierigen Partner zu dem die
Außenministerin am Sonntag reist
Gespräche über Energie sind geplant aber
auch über die Ukraine reichlich
Zündstoff
und das Wetter in der neuen Woche wird
rund um den kalendarischen Sommerbeginn
am Mittwoch schwül Morgen viel Sonne von
der Nordsee bis zum Thüringer Wald im
Südwesten auch einige Schauer und
Gewitter 26 bis 32 Grad an den Küsten
etwas kühler in den nächsten Tagen in
schwüller Luft viele Schauer und
Gewitter teils auch Unwetter durch
Starkregen und Hagel bis zu 33 Grad an
der Nordsee um 22 Grad
zu Beginn der Sendung ging es um
Debatten Kultur den Umgang miteinander
und Wettstreit und damit wollen wir auch
Enten ein gutes Vorbild für uns alle
können die Special Olympic World Games
sein das Sport-Event ist das größte für
Menschen mit geistiger Beeinträchtigung
als der Vorsitzende der Special Olympics
tim ist die Schreiber gestern bei der
Eröffnung in Berlin seine Rede hielt
wurde er ganz spontan von einem
syrischen Athleten umarmt
keine Security weit und breit keine
Vorurteile dafür Vertrauen Freude
Freundlichkeit und zwar bei allen
Athleten die man gestern bei der
Veranstaltung sehen konnte einfach echt
und echte Inklusion
das ZDF berichtet übrigens auch
ausführlich über die Wettkämpfe und das
ganze Drumherum sehr Sehnsucht zum
Beispiel morgen um 12 Uhr zehn und
abends dann erwarten Sie hier Christian
Sievers und Hanna Zimmermann zum heute
schon mal das war's von uns beiden
machen sie es gut wo auch immer sie sind
tschüss
[Musik]